analizamos el avance de la
contraofensiva ucraniana en su
territorio que ha obligado a los rusos a
retroceder esto aunque rusia aseguró que
se fuerzas de misiles y artillería
lanzan ataques masivos contra las
unidades ucranianas en todas las
direcciones operativas incluido el este
y el sur como estamos hablando
precisamente con marta el kremlin
informa de estos ataques después de que
ucrania dijera que recuperó unos 6000
kilómetros cuadrados en territorios
ocupados según el presidente por los
1000 selenski y luego de que las tropas
rusas también se retiraron de
prácticamente toda la región de jarquín
en el este del país a qué se debe todo
este éxito ucraniano y la confianza de
las últimas semanas pues se lo
preguntamos a nuestro primer invitado
ella es ya de la casa susana mangana
profesora e investigar al instituto de
derechos humanos de la universidad
deusto bilbao susana qué gusto tenerla
nuevamente con nosotros esta mañana de
martes aquí en directo américa de france
24 a qué se debe entonces este avance
exitoso de la contraofensiva ucraniana
gusto es mío raúl y efectivamente hoy
los diarios internacionales recogen lo
que han sido las ganancias
contraofensiva ucraniana que no supo ser
vista a tiempo por los altos cargos
militares rusos es decir no pudieron
calibrar que significaba que excellence
que estuviera
desplegando tantas brigadas en el norte
en márquez en el noreste realmente de
ucrania con lo cual hoy se felicitan y
se congratulan aquellos que son aliados
de ucrania pero la guerra todavía está
lejos de terminar por ahora lo que
sabemos es que la moral de los rusos se
va minando y que evidentemente
demuestran fallas sobre todo fallas a
nivel de inteligencia porque no supieron
justamente ver que estaba ocurriendo y
que ofensiva les estaban preparando de
otra manera también hay que recordar que
quizás no son los mejores soldados rusos
los que están desplegados en el
territorio ucraniano supieron asestar
duros golpes a los militares ucranianos
al principio de la guerra llevamos ya
200 días raúl pero evidentemente
excelentes que ha hecho muy gran papel
un muy buen papel a la hora de exigir
armas a occidente y no podemos tampoco
soslayar la importancia que ha tenido en
la contraofensiva ucraniana los
servicios de inteligencia sobre todo de
eeuu que han logrado
ofrecerá zelinski a sus tropas
información vital de los puntos débiles
de los soldados y de los militares rusos
sobre todo porque han golpeado en zonas
como y um que son parte del suministro
vital de las tropas
rusas por otro lado también la
contraofensiva ucraniana lo que ha
sabido manejar muy bien es las armas
combinadas es decir los tanques de
infantería y la artillería pesada junto
con ese servicio de inteligencia
estadounidense que le ha brindado
información muy útil para poder asestar
ese golpe a unas tropas muy débiles por
parte de rusia no no eran suficientes
hombres desplegados en jarque y tampoco
en gerson que son las dos líneas de la
contraofensiva de ucrania que todavía
continúa por estas horas susana hablemos
de este papel principal no protagonista
que han jugado las armas que le ha
entregado occidente a ucrania sin estas
armas es casi no era no se ve digamos
prácticamente imposible que ucrania haya
tenido tanto éxito en esta
contraofensiva en su defensa
es cierto obviamente que también han
pasado ya 200 días de guerra y por tanto
además de brindar armas han brindado
personal militar occidental de varias
naciones de europa sobre todo y de eeuu
que han entrenado a los militares ya los
ciudadanos ucranianos que se han unido
al frente porque han tenido que hacerlo
no sólo porque son patriotas pero
también porque se les ha obligado verdad
hay que recordar eso y por tanto ahora
si ya tienen varios meses de
entrenamiento militar y todo eso
combinado ha hecho que finalmente hayan
has estado este este duro golpe a las
tropas rusas pero que no podemos cantar
victoria insisto creo que por delante
tenemos tres meses muy importantes en
los que también se va a definir cómo
queda la recomposición de fuerzas y
sobre todo hay presión creciente en el
kremlin para que realmente putin admita
que no es una operación militar especial
en ucrania sino que es una guerra porque
no ha enviado por ahora tampoco a todo o
no ha hecho un despliegue como hubiera
hecho antaño en la unión soviética con
lo cual también eso junto con que no hay
un recambio no ha habido oportunidad de
que estos soldados rusos puedan
descansar y recuperarse en el frente
bueno pues evidentemente han hecho que
por ahora haya una victoria pero vamos a
ser cautelosos es una victoria de han
recuperado 40 kilómetros pero zelinski
sabe que se le viene el invierno y
condiciones muy duras para sus militares
eso le quería preguntar susana porque
rusia digamos no termina de endurecer
este ataque porque evidentemente
militarmente rusia tiene una amplitud
sobre ucrania porque no terminan digamos
de hacerlo con toda la artillería que
tiene bueno hay distintas posiciones
también como leía la compañera antes de
dar me pasó a mí y raúl yo creo que
tiene que ver mucho con la posición
ideológica de muchos países y después lo
que trasciende verdad pero yo suscribo
la opinión fíjate del líder checheno
kadyrov que obviamente es afín al
kremlin ya putin que denuncia y ha
criticado muy duramente en las últimas
horas a los puestos de mando a los
militares rusos porque entiende que ha
habido fallos graves colosales en cuanto
a inteligencia que pasa a putin también
no se puede o no se podía permitir
aparentemente uno y brutal desde todas
sus fuerzas allí porque sería admitir
ante su propia ciudadanía que no era
sólo una operación militar sino que era
una guerra a gran escala contra un
pueblo hermano como ha sido el pueblo
ucraniano por más que ahora esa
hermandad ha quedado
indefinidamente dañada y pasarán
generaciones antes de que pueda
recuperarse moralmente y socialmente de
esta herida que está causando la guerra
entre los dos pueblos la zona herida que
sabemos que luego tarda mucho en
cicatrizar la unt susana hay una cosa
muy importante que quiero hablar contigo
y es evidentemente esta confianza no y
este pues crecimiento que ha tenido el
astro pasa ucranianas y sobre todo el
presidente selenski lo vimos en el día
nacional de ucrania diciendo y en el día
de la bandera ucraniana diciendo que la
bandera ucrania iba a ondear nuevamente
en los territorios ocupados e incluso
habló sobre la importancia de recuperar
la península de crimea digamos porque el
presidente es el en sí tiene todo esto
luego estamos viendo esta exitosa
contraofensiva
a qué se debe su sana realmente además
se puede lograr digamos el presidente es
el esquí puede liberar a todo su
territorio de los rusos esto es esto es
posible a ver evidentemente otra vez
aquí hay distintas opiniones si uno le
pregunta a los rusos te dirá que la
contraofensiva no ha sido tan importante
como están indicando la prensa sobre
todo occidental que se hace eco de las
declaraciones de celenque y que
realmente ellos lo que han decidido es
replegarse hacia él
hacia el donbass no hacia la región
donde tienen las dos repúblicas
separatistas no dudan y lo ven espero
pero no es así verdad no no no no
necesariamente tenemos que creer todo lo
que se nos dice en el caso de cesc y
ocurre lo mismo él tiene el deseo pero
es que es un hombre que llevó a
presidente sin demasiados apoyos un
actor muy buenos y sobre todo un
comediante que se había creído el propio
papel de presidente que llevaba adelante
en aquella serie que le sirvió mucho
para saber comunicar sobre todo durante
toda esta guerra lo que ha sido es un
gran publicista y sobre todo ha sabido
encarar a los gobiernos occidentales y
exigir que lo ayuden que se posicionen
rápidamente o con él oa favor de putin y
en ese sentido ha sabido reunir a todas
a toda la ciudadanía ucraniana que
evidentemente no quiere volver a estar
bajo el control o dominio de los rusos
inclusive aquellas zonas como su mí por
ejemplo que eran rosso filas o que
tenían mucha población que habla ruso en
su día a día hoy evidentemente muchos de
ellos también se sienten engañados
traicionados por putin ahora es posible
creer y es factible que va a recuperar
todo el territorio de ucrania pues
claramente que no va a tener que
sentarse a negociar con putin pero
evidentemente esa negociación o el
apalancamiento negociador del presidente
de lenski será diferente si realmente
recupera territorios importantes como la
ciudad de gerson hacia el sur o jarque
por ejemplo eso le va a dar otra otra
dinámica a esa negociación con putin
pero que por ahora no sabemos si hay
disposición de ambos presidentes a
negociar porque mientras te leen es que
crea que puedes seguir avanzando con sus
tropas y reciba más armas y reciba
adiestramiento de occidente continuará
con la contraofensiva y mientras putin
no sea asesorado por sus generales y le
digan mira no es hora de negociar porque
los soldados tienen la moral baja porque
no podemos desplegar
con rapidez las tropas en esas zonas
donde nos están combatiendo y vamos a
perder incluso ciudades vitales para el
suministro de esas tropas como puede ser
y ciu como yo decía hace poco y hace
unos minutos pues entonces putin seguirá
también castigando a ucrania como ya
viene haciendo golpeando donde duele que
es dejando sin luz sin electricidad a la
población